this is a big story about honesty who
are you what scale of impact do you want
to have in this world know someone's
opinion may contradict yours where's my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we if what is the
nature of this reality hey everyone
hello hi hi hello hello it's great to be
here with all your beautiful people
today my name is Alan Saki on I
interview the greatest minds and I
uncover the nature of reality this talk
is going to be about questioning growth
as you can see the color wheel is going
to be an essential analogy that we'll be
visiting
throughout the talk the three key points
that I want us to focus on during the
talk are one know thyself to know the
scale of your impact and three as your
scale increases so does your moral
burden we're all growing individually
and collectively we're going to be
talking about questioning that growth
let's jump in the most ancient advice
knowing yourself who are you what is
your unique gift that you're bringing
into our world
what is that gem inside of you that you
are expressing artistically into the
world
what is your North Star what is your
highest calling how do we uncover this
information about who we are do we need
to pass more time looking in the mirror
looking at ourself in the eyes you know
pass more time journaling reflecting on
who we are and what our unique purpose
is here on the planet another really
strong analogy that I love using is
trees humans are like trees a tree needs
nutrients to flourish it needs soil it
needs water it needs air it needs
sunlight in order for its leaves to
flourish for it to produce fruits same
thing for us as humans we need love from
our parents growing up we need air water
food shelter education electricity
healthcare we need these basic nutrients
in our roots in order for us to be able
to fully express ourselves creatively
and for those fruits to land for
ourselves our families our communities
our country in the world and sometimes
there are deficiencies in the nutrients
and the roots you may not have gotten
that love you may have been malnourished
growing up but do you see those greatest
traumas as your greatest treasures all
right
let's move in to what is the center
point of the talk the scale of your
impact all of these different colors on
the color wheel are options for a gift
that you can bring into the world
whatever your unique gift is too
frequently we forget where it slips our
mind that even being a good mom or dad
is a gift
being a good family member is a gift
that you can bring to the world and
that's it it can be as simple as that
are you helping someone with a
disability helping someone that's
injured helping someone that's sick that
can be a gift something as simple as
that is somewhere on the color wheel
of impact let's go to another example
maybe you're a musician but you're a
musician that only plays at a local
venue once a week that's it people come
up to you put your music on soundcloud
on youtube on spotify and the musician
says no i want to play once a week here
at this venue that's it now let's just
suppose that musician with another
artist that wants to go and perform at
American Idol they want to go and be
known by the whole world for their music
or their art are we starting to see
these scales of impact yes are we
excellent okay so we can start seeing
these scales of impact and when we get
ourselves behind the perspective of
people that are trying to make this type
of global style influence how much time
do we think that they have for their
family how much time do they have to
raise their kids how much time do they
have to take a hike versus someone
that's only playing once a week at their
local venue let's do another example
let's say your grandma made the best
cookies the best cookies your family and
your friends are constantly we have some
more of the cookies we want more of the
cookies and so you say okay I'm gonna
open up a brick-and-mortar location in
my community to sell these cookies I
have five employees okay we have five
employees we after taxes make $50,000 a
year over four thousand dollars a month
is that your color on the color wheel
are you content with five employees and
$50,000 a year
let the juxtapose that again another
option oh my gosh these cookies I have
to get one cookie to everybody on the
planet I have to do direct-to-consumer
and so on my website I have to sell on
Amazon I need a cookie warehouse a
cookie factory I have to branch out 50
franchises is that you now again we see
this juxtaposition and scales and we
hear so often this story the story of
the person opens their second
brick-and-mortar cookie location and
they go holy crap I can't handle this I
can't I can't do this I can't split
myself I'm not a cell that can just
divide and go into both locations at the
same time the supply chains getting
crazy I can spend less time with my
family so what happens they actually
take a step back in order to take a step
forward
so we see there's all these different
types of ways to question growth and the
questions scale of impact now
there's options to try and get your song
to eight billion people options to try
and get a cookie to eight billion people
but what about the 1 billion humans that
have some sort of a disability whether
it be a speech disability whether it be
a motor disability visual disability
hearing disability cognitive disability
1 billion people with a disability
our friends ondrea's for slen and
cognition are making AI ottoman tations
to people with disabilities so that they
can learn to communicate so they can
express their unique gifts into the
world so now how quickly is it important
for us to work together as a social
fabric to help that style of impact get
to 1 billion people as fast as possible
so we have that style of scale as well
want to take something that ethically
sits in our hearts a little bit more and
maybe we want to help that get to scale
faster ok in this example here a company
that was founded 16 years ago in 2004
this company's Facebook this company
that starts at Harvard and then it goes
to more schools in Boston and then it
goes to more Ivy League universities and
then it goes to universities around the
country and then it goes to corporations
and then it goes to universities abroad
overseas and then it goes to high
schools in the United States then
businesses come onto the platform then
they had advertising in their business
pages and then in 2012 they buy
Instagram in 2012 they have an IPO in
2014 they buy whatsapp in 2014 they buy
oculus in 2016 all of the issues happen
with the political election and now
having to deal with misinformation
having to deal with court hearings
in 2019 announcing Libra cryptocurrency
in 2019 getting involved with brain
computer interfaces with control labs
mathematical physicist and economist
Eric Weinstein calls this an ego an
embedded growth obligation there is now
shareholders that want to make dividends
there is now the need for me to connect
all people people in Africa people in
Asia people in South America we need to
keep growing we need to keep buying the
newest and newest technologies and
continue growing questioning this style
of growth and this is not just with an
organization like Facebook this is seen
with Google's of the world the Amazons
of the world the apples of the world
lubbers LinkedIn's Twitter's let's go to
Asia let's look at $0.10 let's look at
Alibaba let's look at Baidu
it's happening all over the place these
embedded growth obligations to question
who are we as a company and what is our
purpose and so much of our attention is
focused on this the news is focused on
it there's this new entrepreneur
billionaire effect that's being cascaded
around our world where it's all so much
of it's just focused on that and out of
all of these options on the color wheel
Gary Vaynerchuk who's an entrepreneur
and a speaker talks about this deep
misalignment that's happening where so
much of our attention is being focused
on this single area of the color wheel
billionaire entrepreneurship that we
forget that even being a good parent or
being a musician in a vended place once
a week in a venue or that has one
brick-and-mortar store something to
applaud that we must applaud our friends
and our communities that do just that
there's also affecting this style of
zeitgeist in our culture is what we see
on Instagram what we see hot women with
throwing around money
yotz yotz with not enough we need a pool
we need a slide from the third story we
need four jet skis we need private jets
because screw TSA screws to our weights
you know I want the whole plane to
myself gold-plated everything gold and
diamonds on my wrist absolutely mansions
mansions with so many rooms so many
rooms that are so unoccupied all year
long
this is actually a deep part of our
evolution Richard Dawkins who's an
evolutionary biologist calls this the
extended phenotype we portray ourselves
and our status in the hierarchy so that
we can get better mates so that we can
get better business contacts and better
friends so this is a very natural thing
but we also have to realize that a lot
of the times this happens and as rapper
and producer Kanye West says one of my
favorite lyrics of his $2,000 bag wit no
cash in your purse here we go and buy
this purse with every last dollar I have
and you can't put any money in it you're
trying to flaunt it around can't even
put any money in it so this is a big
story about honesty who are you what
scale of impact do you want to have in
this world and not to just be looking at
that one tiny sliver of billionaire
entrepreneurship we have to remember
that as scale increases so does the
Burdon yes the person in the cookie shop
that has five employees has to take care
of their employees and they have a moral
burden but there's also a massive moral
burden on the people that we were just
mentioning here's Mark Zuckerberg and
Priscilla Chan with the Chan Zuckerberg
initiative that are trying to do things
like cure all diseases this is extremely
hard work massive teams of scientists
and researchers pushing the edge of
what's known in science in healthcare
also very similarly with Bill and
Melinda Gates eradicating disease
maximizing flourishing this is what
happens a lot when you gain such status
and such wealth and such scale of impact
is all of a sudden now the Giving Pledge
happens you have to be willing to give
99% of your billions of dollars that
you've earned to give back to the world
that you actually got that value from
these are also visionaries there becomes
a burden to become a visionary when we
talk to all these different indigenous
tribes from around our planet something
that we hear over and over again is
their interconnectedness with nature
they're deep interconnectedness with
nature the same air that I breathe in is
the same air that phytoplankton and
trees breathe out the same water that we
drink today is part of the hydrological
cycle that was here when dinosaurs were
drinking it it's so deeply
interconnected you take the bite of the
Apple it comes from the power of the Sun
to nourish you to energize you that
these principles are then communicated
to people that have this burden to then
build that next world something like a
seven generation principle not even
making a move until you think seven
generations ahead 200 years ahead about
how that's going to influence the kids
kids kids kids kids kids kids
what if every action we took was like
that another one inclusive steak holding
this is something that Joon Yoon who's a
physician and hedge fund manager is
pioneering with redesigning the social
contract for inclusive steak holding
these companies and where they're
located in their communities as well as
the way that they influence the
environment the way that they influence
those next generations there needs to be
a style of inclusive steak holding for
redesigning the social contract so again
there's a burden for them to be
visionaires if you want to have a higher
scale of impact you're gonna have to
have a higher moral burden on yourself
to be a visionary of the next world
okay so let's review the three key
takeaways first know thyself second your
scale of impact and third as you
increase your scale there will be an
increase of moral burden I want to end
with a story the story comes from
physician and entrepreneur dr. George
Lane he's on our show we're interviewing
him he's talking about how he took a
year off before continuing to med school
on toast trajectory during that year off
he was a science teacher in qatal a in
Kenya in rural Kenya he was a science
teacher there's no electricity there's
no running water women are taking urns
with them to go and walk far to get
water and come back every day
they get a tap installed while he's
there so they finally get a tap
installed in their village while he's
there very close by he in the morning
wakes up with the Sun has his cup he
walks over to the tap he gets just
enough water for brushing his teeth and
for getting his coffee and he sees the
women are socializing having a great
time waiting in line to fill up their
urns with water and he as the science
teacher gets to walk up to the front
with just his little cup and ask may I
please just fill up my little cup and
you know him being a respected science
teacher they say of course so he fills
up his cup and he notices that the
faucet is barely opened and the water is
coming out very slowly
and he thinks to himself well maybe they
don't understand how the faucet works
that they can actually open it up more
and have water come faster and so he
thinks okay let me show them so he shows
them and the water comes out faster he
looks at that and they look back over
take the faucet close it back to the
same speed that it was at before and
they look and say what's the rush
thank you would like to see if we have
maybe a question or two from the
audience I would love to answer Kari has
a microphone so if there is a question
or two about questioning growth about
these different colors on the color
wheel
I'd love to field them huh yes please
oh there's something might come anyway
yeah you mention about knowing thyself
and how does one get to do that so is
there a process that you believe there
is or is it by introspection what's your
name my name is Vicky Bedi from India
one more time on the name HS Bedi BDI
Bedi HS baby good to meet you thank you
for the question
um may I ask are you sick do you seek it
yeah okay um Sikhism is is very
beautiful I am a Sikh and I happen to be
the 14th descendant of the founder of
the Sikh religion Guru Nanak beautiful
thank you beautiful
something that I've learned about this
process is that every single one of us
has their own unique way of communing
with the nature of this reality we have
8 billion of us meaning there are 8
billion unique ways of communing with
this nature of the reality with a higher
power or a higher purpose for you to
know yourself I gave those couple
examples looking at yourself in the
mirror journaling introspection through
meditation you know here we are in the
Bay Area if you want to partake in some
entheogens or psychedelics you can do
that right there's so many of these
different paths for you to take
exploring the religions or
spiritualities of the world just taking
a little bit of time to look deeply in
the eyes of your mother or father for
even just 60 seconds and just being
there and not breaking eye contact not
laughing and not talking but just
looking at them in the eyes all these
different ways are deeper ways to
commune and to know yourself better but
the buffet of options is unlimited and
so every one of us gets to play around
and figure out what is our unique way of
knowing ourselves we have another maybe
one more question before we go
that's all okay just quickly you guys
are about to go to lunch right Oscar has
been talking about this a lot that what
happens is that we participate and then
we go off into the rest of our days and
then we don't integrate right we need to
integrate and what are is one of the
best ways to integrate is to make things
into habits right so if like Pascal
mentioned earlier if we're not taking
time to think about what's gonna be
happening in the future and what's my
role in the future if we're not taking
the time to journal and reflect about
who we are today to close our eyes and
be still for even just a minute then
we're not gonna as easily know ourselves
we're not gonna as easily know the scale
of our impact to question growth so turn
these into habits and at lunch maybe ask
each other ask each other about who are
you really deep down in your core and
what scale of impact do you want to have
on the world so begin the process of
turning this into an into a habit thank
you so much for having me here I really
appreciate you all so much thank you
thank you everyone
we're done okay Thank You Ellen
[Music]